[Applaudissements]
pas joli joli
voilà je pense qu'il y aura un après 7h
briques non c'est vrai c'est vraiment
vers la baston aujourd'hui elle est
toute une question
merde bonjour je m'appelle catherine
j'ai adoré la séquence où vous êtes mis
du nutella sur les dents car je suis
passionné par tout ce qui touche les
médias mais je voulais savoir combien de
personnes ont travaillé sur ce projet
mais proposeront tous ses aspects soeur
catherine car c'est vrai que c'était un
grand moment de la télévision française
je vous rappelle le principe des
happenings les chroniqueurs devait se
mettre de la pâte à tartiner et se
retourner en faisant une imitation de
jacquouille la fripouille tout de suite
un rappel des faits christophe carrière
ok j'arrive au valais les mairies
gilles verdez locale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'oublie
aujourd'hui la meilleure de la trouille
je crois que c'est benhaim la sent une
réelle et il va s'en faudrait l'appeler
jusqu'à la fin de saison jacquouille ah
mais c'est là jacques oudart va vous
voulez rediffusé halloween à la belle
étoile me suis super bien brassens avait
complimenté les femmes en tout cas comme
d'habitude vous aurez noté la sobriété
de gilles verdez qui crachent pas bien
sachez que j'ai des images du making of
de cette séquence mais je ne diffuserait
pas à pas dans sinon mes collègues
perdrait tout dire que vous avez raison
et puis je vais être honnête pour une
fois je suis tombé sur un os sympa me
concernant donc donc ça m'a touché
surtout de la part de jean-michel je
voulais te remercier vraiment c'est
bravo et c'était le jour où je vous
remplacez la présentation assez gentil
toujours
c'est bien ce tour caressait
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non finalement ils se foutent de ma
gueule donc à cause de jean michel mr
toute la classe va être puni
voici la préparation du happening
nutella et le pôle si vous allez voir
c'est qu'à la fin vous allez voir
thierry moreau super concentré en train
de répéter son texte qui était très
puisque je vous le rappelle le texte est
ok mais à y regarder les forts que ça
lui demande s'il va un peu vite s'il
vous plaît
jean-luc tabou et nos testeurs kader
hockey
terim au hockey
[Applaudissements]
oublié son texte quand même élan stress
de poules grâce que j'écoute au fond les
autres c'est ça c'est le jour de ma vie
je vais pas critiquer thierry may mais
franchement c'est celui qui fait les
têtes et plus étrange dans l'équipe
je préviens le programme déjà il part
avec une tête étrangers oui c'est pire
qu'au comme rigole oui c'est vrai je
vous préviens la prochaine tête m'a fait
peur on aime ta différence
non vous allez voir ça commence comme le
rire le plus long de l'histoire de la
télé ça s'arrête et après je ne sais pas
ce qui se passe cyril et s'adresser à
gérard louvin a super bien même ce que
c'était encore chaud
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
je suis en est encore une fois
je suis pas langue de bois j'aimerais
dire non parce que ça ne se voit pas et
c'est vrai que si les séries je vois pas
du tout je savais pas moi je ne savais
pas moi même j'aurais mieux fait de
fermer ma gueule
[Rires]
parti il faut dire que ce que préfère
tirer dans la vie c'est les vannes sur
gérard louvin